AFTER A MILD HEART ATTACK.
LARRY KUDLOW IS SAID TO BE IN
GOOD CONDITION AT WALTER REED
MEDICAL CENTER IN MARYLAND.
THE NUMBER TWO OFFICIAL IN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS PLAYING
HARDBALL WITH CONGRESSIONAL
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE
INVESTIGATING THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION PROBE.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE
CORRESPONDENCE
CATHERINE HERRIDGE IS IN
WASHINGTON TONIGHT TO TELL US
ABOUT IT.
HELLO, CATHERINE.
>> THE EMAILS BY FOX NEWS WERE
SENT TO DOCUMENT THE JANUARY
CLOSED-DOOR MEETING THAT
INCLUDED ROD ROSENSTEIN.
CHRISTOPHER WRAY, THEIR SENIOR
ADVISORS AS WELL AS THE
REPUBLICAN HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE CHAIR DEVIN NUNES AND
HIS SENIOR STAFF.
THE ACCOUNT CLAIM ROSENSTEIN
QUIPPED ON MY THREATEN TO TURN
THE TABLE ON THE COMMITTEE
REGARDING THE RUSSIAN TROLL.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD
ROSENSTEIN CRITICIZED THE
COMMITTEE FOR SENDING A REQUEST
IN WRITING AND WAS FOR THE
CRITICAL OF THE COMMITTEE'S
REQUEST TO HAVE DOJ DO THE SAME
WHEN RESPONDING.
GOING TO FAR AS TO SAY AS IF THE
COMMITTEE LIKES BEING
LITIGATORS, THEN WE, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, TOO ARE LITIGATORS
AND WE WILL SUBPOENA YOUR
RECORDS AND YOUR EMAILS
REFERRING TO THE HOUSE COMMITTEE
AND CONGRESS OVERALL.
THE EMAILS REVIEWED BY HOUSE --
BACKED UP THE ACCOUNT.
WRITING "LET ME JUST ADD THAT
WATCHING THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL LAUNCHED A
SUSTAINED PERSONAL ATTACK
AGAINST A CONGRESSIONAL STAFFER
IN RETALIATION FOR VIGOROUS
OVERSIGHT WAS ASTONISHING AND
DISHEARTENING."
ALSO HAVING THE NATION'S NUMBER
ONE FOR THESE MATTERS,
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
THREATENED TO SUBPOENA YOUR
CALLS IN YOUR EMAILS WAS DOWN
LIKE CHILLING.
BOTH THE FBI AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT DISPUTED THE
IMPLICATION.
ROSENSTEIN NEVER THREATENED A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION WRITING
THAT HAPPY ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS
MAKING THE POINT AFTER BEING
THREATENED WITH CONTEMPT THAT IS
AMERICAN CITIZEN CHARGED WITH
THE DASH HE WOULD HAVE TO RIGHT
TO DEFEND HIMSELF.
INCLUDING RELEVANT EMAILS AND
TEXT MESSAGES AND CALLING THEM
AS WITNESSES TO DEMONSTRATE THAT
THEIR ALLEGATIONS ARE FALSE.
THE OFFICIAL WENT FURTHER SAYING
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
"WILL FURTHER REQUEST THE HOUSE
GENERAL COUNSEL CONDUCT AN
INTERNAL INVESTIGATION OF THIS
CONGRESSIONAL MEMBERS CONDUCT
ADDING THE CHAIRMAN DID NOT
COMPLAIN AFTER THE MEETING.
AND THEN STATEMENT TO FOX NEWS
THEY SAID THEY TAKE THE STUFF
SERIOUSLY.
THEY HAVE ENCOURAGED THE
COMMITTEE TO WORK THROUGH THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT INSPECTOR'S